creates everyone I'm a lotta and welcome
to my channel if I look like complete
but it's because I just got back from
Australia I guess today so I'm pretty
jet-lagged it's a 1 a.m. and right now
I'm wide awake walk tomorrow this guess
but today I wanted to talk about patreon
this video isn't Papa the creator's up
and you've been thinking about getting a
patreon and aren't sure I have questions
and also for the audience's who are both
supportive all very against patreon I
guess I just wanted to talk about some
of the stuff that goes on behind the
scenes because I feel like a lot of
people have questions about this I
started my patreon almost a year ago and
it has had what I would call a
profoundly positive impact on my life
and has contributed to things that I
will never forget
they're also incredible downsides and
I'm gonna start with the downsides just
because they prefer to in the video on
high note so first things first patreon
is incredibly hard work now I'm sure
this depends on the person and I'm sure
there are some people out there as the
joke goes that just post photos of them
half-naked and don't really do anything
but that does not apply to majority of
creators on patreon and assuming that
most of those people who are on patreon
all creative types you probably struggle
with very similar things as what I
currently do I know this is not just me
I know people who've left patreon
because of this basically having a
patreon makes you feel guilty every
waking minute that you aren't working I
already work pretty much constantly but
today for a couple of hours they went to
a park and then went and had some
Japanese food with some friends and I
brought up patreon twice in that span of
time I left early so that I could work
on patreon stuff and I was just
constantly thinking about it anytime
that I do something that is fun I feel
guilty any time that I do something in
my own time I feel guilty because I know
that there are people who are supporting
me and who are giving me their money and
it just really honestly feels unhealthy
and I've always had an unhealthy
relationship with work but having a
full-time job and a part-time job that
is funded by people who admire you is
like some next-level [ __ ] and it's sad
because sometimes I'll miss people's
messages I lost my SD card last week so
I couldn't post the videos that I had
planned and recorded for people while I
was on vacation in Australia I had to
while I was in Australia [ __ ]
scramble to get my pot
stop and I had to ask my mom and my aunt
to do it because my sister was supposed
to and couldn't because she was sick the
first day but I owe these people that
contact basically if you are a creative
type if you have anything like imposter
syndrome patreon is is going to be hard
for you mentally and it really is for me
the top tier that I have on patreon are
probably the people who are most loyal
to me and the people I know by name
they're the people who've been watching
my content for a long time I spend about
40 hours a month on our mailing rewards
to those people and I still feel [ __ ]
terrible anytime that there's an issue
or like one gets sent back or something
hasn't arrived or something out of my
control is going wrong I suppose it
comes down to just caring too much but
it's very hard not to especially when
you feel like those people care about
you so the other thing they don't tell
you is that patreon at least for me took
about 50% of my earnings come tax time
yes I think it's April 18th is tax day
in the US and I expected to be taxed a
few thousand dollars but I didn't expect
to be taxed as much as I was and it
crippled my bank account so when you see
someone's like public earnings take
about 50 percent off that and that's
what they actually own maybe works
differently for people who have like
registered businesses or something like
that or if it's that sole income but for
me it was brutal so just keep that in
mind it's not as much money as you think
it is - the positives and they obviously
outweigh the negatives for me the
patreon community is always going to be
your core in SIF you are a creator and
you have a hundred thousand followers
the people who will support you on
patreon are the ones who care the most
about your content basically that means
that I can throw ideas at people on
patreon and get really really useful
feedback the kind that if I put up on
YouTube or in Twitter people who might
give feedback but don't even watch the
content so it's you know it's not
genuine feedback I can post a video and
be like hey guys I feel like this video
is controversial I feel like I maybe
didn't express myself well should I even
post this publicly and there have been
two videos that I did not post publicly
because my support has said no I get
what you were trying to say but you
failed maybe don't post this publicly
I've had the opposite where I'm a
patreon exclusive videos that one may be
about slightly controversial topics and
they said hey
I know this is an exclusive but you
shouldn't post this publicly what you're
saying will be valuable to other people
and I hope that you share this with
everyone and that kind of stuff is like
you can't you really get that from
friends you can't get that from a
broader audience on YouTube
there isn't any system that's tied in to
really help you with that kind of stuff
and so on that note the patreon
community is the most supportive online
community that I've ever encountered and
that's definitely not to say that people
on patreon are just unanimously nice all
the time because they are they give
valuable feedback but it's like feedback
from people who know you a little better
and care about you a little more
probably a lot more there are things
that I've shed on patreon that I want
show anywhere else and that's really
nice as well I've been going through
some tough [ __ ] recently and patreon
knows about a huge chunk of it and it's
just been so I don't know incredibly
supportive when I said that patron has
made an incredible and unforgettable
impact on my life
I meant that and that's something that I
can't talk about publicly because it
involves someone else it was going
through something that I picture and
helped me help them with and I I can't
really speak about that publicly because
of that person but they were just so
incredibly kind and I don't know it
feels like having a family it's just as
soon as someone subscribes to your
content it generally means that they are
invested in your content and care about
you and can have an open dialogue with
you provide useful but encouraging
feedback and criticism while also giving
you some guidance on your content
because I don't know if other creators
are like me but honestly I'm just
[ __ ] flailing around out here I have
no idea what to post since I stopped
being allowed to talk about games on my
channel and I don't broken that rule a
few times recently it's like I don't
know what people want you know post
something and it'll get a lot of views
and I'd be like well if I do that coming
for them I post something that I think
will get a lot of using it doesn't click
on so it's really really handy having
this small a group of people that you
could be like hey here's what I'm
thinking about posting this month do you
guys want to see more of this do you
guys want to see this which of these
would you prefer and you just have that
died incentives it's so valuable it's
also an incredible motivator in
I didn't used to post videos every week
I only started doing that when I go to
patreon and to give you some perspective
I don't think I'm actually allowed to
talk about this explicitly but my
youtube channel makes next to no money
it barely covers my phone bill people
have this perception that it makes a lot
more than it doesn't it doesn't know
what so that's also part of it of course
financially I wouldn't still have this
YouTube channel and I wouldn't be
posting weekly if I didn't have patreon
I would not have been able to start a
podcast by the microphones by the
editing software pay the graphic artist
I wouldn't have been able to do any of
that stuff that I did without a patreon
so it can open up new doors and it makes
the doors that you do have open just
feel so much more valuable I suppose so
to everyone who's supporting me on
patreon seriously thank you I mean I
tell you guys all the time thank you so
much it's it's really incredible but to
the people who are watching this who are
creators who a hesitant to start a
patreon you will get shot people will be
mean to you when you start one though
they'll treat you like you're not doing
any work or like you don't deserve it
and that's just not at all true the act
of being a patron has existed the
centuries people who support creators
they like is not a new concept just keep
that in mind and remember that it really
the positives really do outweigh the
negatives but also make sure that you
save money because you will get texts a
lot and I think that's it for me today
everyone umm just felt like now is the
right time to say this there may be some
changes coming to my picture in the
coming months but I just wanted to get
southern now like the people on my
patreon know just really motivated and
inspired me in their own ways and
alright this is the part of the video
where I thank everyone who's supporting
me on patreon all the names that are on
screen right now those are the people
who get my rewards and stuff and I hope
that those of you are thinking about
starting one well he were critical of
others who do kind of like get more of a
perspective on it now alright I'm Alana
and I will see you guys next time